hey what's up guys Mary here and i'm
here with forest and you're going to
show me the flame and the flood today
yeah that's correct it's a game i've
been working on for the last year and a
half about since we kick started and
we're getting very very close to release
so I'm just kind of traveling around
right now to show it off to folks and
give them an idea of what what we've got
coming ya know this is you'll have to
help me with the definition of this type
of game because I would consider it more
of like a survival roguelike esque game
because it's got procedural generation
and permadeath once you die you have to
kind of start over yep but it looks like
you can continue if you want to end and
come back to it yeah so there's
checkpoints along the way like not that
you can you know return to but more so
if you quit and come back and that's
like the normal way to play it we also
with this release we haven't had this in
early access but we've introduced like a
easier difficulty mode for the campaign
which itself is also new and there are
like actual checkpoints that you can
rewind to if you're playing in the
easier mode just because not everybody
really likes that sort of process of
dying and starting over from the very
beginning so if folks want to play the
game just because they like the music
and they think it's you know they like
the art it's a little bit easier
forgiving a little bit although I still
watch people when they're playing it
kind of pancake within you know 15
minutes of starting a new game on the
easier mode so um we're gonna start
right now then and are you going to
continue yeah I figured since the game
sort of builds up over time I'm gonna
continue and hope that we see some more
wildlife than what you see early on um I
don't really know where the save game
was left off so I guess we're gonna find
out all right I'm looking forward to it
so tell me a little bit of the backstory
of what you're doing here um so right
now i guess the stuff that we're
skipping over is at the very start of
the game like in the menu see the
skeleton in the bag and the dog drags
the bag away from the skeleton and then
when the game begins you see the dry the
dog dragging the bag through the woods
and he comes to scout which is the
character you play as sitting at a fire
he brings the bag to her there's a radio
in it she checks it and there's a
garbled signal so your first goal at
this point is to find high ground so you
can
hear this signal and the hope is to find
some sort of help other people something
like that she's basically fully alone in
the wilderness and the player doesn't
really understand what she's doing out
alone in the wilderness either like
she's all alone she's got nothing but
this raft a dog and some supplies that
she's finding along the way so is there
any more explanation to like what you're
doing out here like what happened
besides obviously there's clearly a
flood and yeah so that's sort of that
that is something that unravels over
time particularly in campaign you do
find along the way various little bits
of story and you encounter people and
have conversations with them and they
sort of fill in a bit of what happened
around the world all right so right now
on the players watching you you in real
time you move your raft around you got
to avoid rocks or you can harm your raft
and yourself yep yep that's correct and
now you've just found a docking point to
explore what get more items things like
that for survival yep that's the idea so
I stopped at a camp I'm gonna shoe that
crow away and camps are rich in certain
types of supplies let's see it's
nighttime so I'm passing a rabbit hole
right now which is why this um you'll
see you like little tutorials and stuff
pop up they only ever happen the first
time you play right now let's see I'm
going to check my inventory because I'm
starting a new game I want to see the
stuff that I've got all right I'm
actually being I'm going to eat some
mulberries that I collected earlier okay
yeah I can see your hunger bar at the
bottom thirst your body temperature so
you can't get cold maybe when it rains
yep yep and uh it gets colder at night
okay I'm actually and then fatigue and
then there's also above your person she
looks a little beat up her eyes a pre
sad there yeah you can see a stamina bar
yep and that'll change probably when
she's fighting somebody maybe yeah so
when you sprint around like you can see
that that's it's going down but actually
i'm going to this is kind of our
equivalent of audio logs there there are
quilts this actually came from one of
our kickstarter backers we had a design
a character tier
and one person didn't really want to
design a character she just asked if we
could put a quilt in the game so we're
using these as sort of a storytelling
thing you can find these quilts and find
these little stories in them and they're
actually written by Joe fielder who was
one of the writers on BioShock Infinite
and is currently working on underworld
ascendant now a lot of you guys have
great pedigrees you yourself feast or
get irrational games as well yep yeah
all the team did at one point you were a
level designer that's correct i was i
was the lead level designer on the team
so what inspired you guys kind of break
away and make this one well I mean the
simplest answer is a rational downsized
and we were out of work um let's see
there's so there's a boar over there oh
he's coming after you yes he is i kind
of irritated him i don't really have
enough supplies to fight him yeah so
combat in this game is largely based on
okay i was looking here alright alright
well i'm near a fire now so i'm a little
safe like he's gonna kind of stay away
okay so I can collect some stuff it
looks like you're choosing him a little
bit oh sure oh sorry i cursed I think
I'm supposed to keep my language clean
uh yeah he startled me they'll be fine
oh let's see you know what all the time
I'm gonna run out of here because I
don't have the stuff that I need to make
a trap and if you know obviously oh
there was a rabbit I do have there's
another rabbit right there yeah so let
me see if I can find um but if you if
you become injured you don't have a lot
of options right like you basically you
need a splint or to find or can you make
items as well to heal yourself yeah you
can make items so there's nothing that
can happen to you that there isn't a
solution for but like a big part of
learning the game is learning that like
learning what you need to carry with you
all right oh let's see hey bunny rabbit
it isn't are you gonna try scam in
towards the trucks oh great all right
there we go a lot of people might find
some kind of similar slim similarities
with this with that
don't starve or something where you're
kind of like constantly fighting the
elements but you have added a really
great story element to this as well so
not only are trying to survive but
there's obviously something else going
on in the world that's continuously
happening that you get to return to and
keep trying to find more information
about yeah that probably keeps the
player more interested because you know
it can get really daunting just
constantly trying to live and then once
you find out how to live what's the
motivation to keep playing well so
that's part of there's a couple like
there is just endless mode and a lot of
people like that's what's been in early
access and a lot of people are just
playing it just to see how far they can
make it we've seen people make it
incredible difference is that I wouldn't
have predicted were possible um within
in campaign as well there's uh like
right now I'm just trying to get
downriver you know I'm actually gonna
well I'm gonna oh no all right I'm
driving really poorly right now okay but
this is a really good to show show
everybody this new element that I've
never seen in a game before which is not
only is it a survival game but now you
don't like this live action sequence
where you have to dodge and there you're
able to kind of shift your vote really
quickly it does take stamina though does
it not yeah yeah you basically get for
boosts for three depending on the
difficulty that you're on um when you
get some Rapids you gonna be really
quick actually yeah yeah and really the
idea of the river is it's just it's a
force that's always pushing you along
I'm gonna stop here because there's a
really good chance that there's water
and I really
I will really need water um but yeah
like much like an actual river I'm going
to be able to track to you can't really
fully fight the current you just sort of
need to work with it and that was one of
the sort of the key ideas of the river
is like as you're traveling down you're
seeing these different locations and
deciding like where the important ones
where you need to stop
and there's a risk and reward with
stopping as well like you'll find items
but there's also the potential that
you'll run into war or wolf or something
way great you if you're not prepared
alright so okay I'm just gonna eat the
starlet because I don't need anything
else to do it okay and there's actually
let's see is a couple things here that
are useful so I'm gonna grab some
saplings I'm gonna go over this well and
just up fill up my water jar great you
know actually I'm gonna really drink it
yeah I'm finna demonstrate yeah the well
you only get one use whenever you find a
well oh that's a shame how do you kind
of you know I've seen sometimes you find
water it's not mean well Ellie looks
great so this is also randomly along the
river you can find NPCs that might help
you out a little bit looks really nutso
yeah all right I'm gonna kind of zip
through this actually so this might not
be story related this is just a random
generation of someone who can help you
yeah so basically NPCs either like
filling some backstory around the world
or they do show up in like the main
campaign or they can offer to trade like
in her case if you you know select a
story to tell her i forget what she
gives you she gives you something i
think she made a trap or something okay
i'm gonna give that all right because
you told her an amusing anecdote yes I
assume she's a heavy southern roll we
get to fill in with our own imagination
yeah yeah we didn't really didn't want
to do voice recordings for this mostly
there's like a lot of things that we've
elected oh cool there's another one
right um but there is some tremendous
sound design so where there's not
character audio you Boateng's probably
here right now there's beautiful music
in the background with Mirax you guys
chose lyrical background music which is
a great touch to kind of help with the
loneliness the player might feel ya I
thought it was like a nice contrast with
the quietness of the game yeah I mean
working on the music was great we
actually had just sent the musician
chuck ragan a long list of sort of you
know words that if were associated with
sort of feelings and ideas that we
wanted to convey in the game and I'm
gonna eat this whole stack and he just
he wrote an album based on that which is
coming out very soon and actually if
folks are watching this and are on the
East Coast he's going to be touring in
February playing a bunch of venues in
the Northeast they go to the if they
have to be from Boston and you can see
the show at the sinclair i bet you
you'll run into the whole molasses flood
team which is all of us now does your
dog have any what else does your dog
help you with so he calls out um you
know objects like threats in the world
and things that you can collect and he
also served as like an expansion to your
inventory and one of the nice things
about him is when you die when you start
over anything that was stored on his bag
you start out with so when you're sort
of in the the death throes it's a good
idea to kind of go into your inventory
and figure out like okay I want this
beer Trappe in my next life so I'm going
to move it to him got it alright well
that's an interesting touch cuz you guys
you guys take some liberties with the
realism of this game I know
if you break your leg let's say and use
a splint you're like magically running
again yeah look we tried to like
everything's supposed to be based sort
of in like it comes from a place of
authenticity but they're certainly like
fudging here and there for the sake of
gameplay but there was like a ton of
research that went into just figuring
out like well what are the plants that
you can yeah I from yeah like what what
heals what deals you you know you
collect things like like a low for a
burn do you have to conduct research to
know these things or does the player
already come with a lot of this
information the player like this info is
in the journal right from the get-go
okay you do unlock recipes like you get
little pop-ups as you collect all the
supplies needed oh crap but yeah there's
not like there's not sort of research
that you need to invest in oh but yes as
recipes become available they alert you
in the HUD that now you can make this
now you can make that you know I'm
actually doing in good shape so I'm
going to kind of bomb down the river I'm
going to see I can make it
I don't think I'm gonna have time
there's some more rapid yeah I'm kind of
gonna stay out of them a little bit
because I'm a little bit of a weenie and
I don't want to die oh yeah it's pretty
dangerous oh you guys I am gonna go over
here okay so you can loot in the water
and it's kind of prompted by those
little circles that let you know a
little highlight yeah yeah look if you
look closely it's a little little red
shopping cart actually so keep your eye
out for the shopping carts dog at the
helm yeah so that's in a whole mess of
debris right now
visually a very beautiful game there's
obviously been a lot of work into the
details of this how many people do you
have working on that the total team size
is 6 so it's really the art team is
three people there's um our art director
sync was our director on bioshock and
bioshock infinite and he kind of makes
all of the like all the the textures all
the models that you see in the world and
then there was a chad who is the
environment artist and he sort of puts
it all together in the world and then
last member the our team has blend who
does animator she's an animator and does
a lot of tech art so really like the
world that you're seeing like the actual
pixels on the screen we're built
entirely by two people yeah it's really
tremendous and they've done a great job
with keeping the water in the same style
as the game which i think is is a lot of
times something that's more difficult
than you might think it's it's not
you've done a good job nothing else in
the game is realistic it's got a really
brilliant art style that's fluid
throughout all of it and you still found
a way to make the rapids look completely
different than Stillwater yeah yeah well
and we wanted that too it is challenging
because there's like an inclination with
a you know especially we're using like
the Unreal Engine there's all these sort
of like water plugins that just make
like super realistic water but that was
like maybe the easiest way to go she's
got water droplets coming off her
because she's wet yeah you can also see
that because there's a little icon above
her saying she's currently wet know
what's the one on the right that's its
shirt that's got an arrow below that
mean yeah that means I'm ill-equipped
and what that means is that the air
temperature is much lower than
the key trading my clothing so if I look
here like you can see over on the right
I'm only I'm wearing like cotton pants
light foots like basically starting
equipment right and air temperature is
way lower than my gear rating so I'm
getting colder I'm actually going to get
to sleep for just a minute which will
also drive me off and warm me up a
little bit right and it's good it's
letting you know ahead of time when
you're sleeping how hungry and how
thirsty you're going to be when you hook
up so you have to give yourself some
rest but maybe not as much as you would
like four hours is not enough for a
young adventurer no I'm getting pretty
hungry I'm gonna see tonight do that
rabbit already know do you need to cook
it in the in a camp yeah i was gonna
make a campfire okay and cook it up oh
no what did I use that I needed Oh to
make your fire ride I used something
I've like I'll just make the hammer uh
oh my Flint okay how hard is it to
obtain new flint cuz it's all random
right you should yeah you should know
your odds yeah I guess I wasn't paying
attention um I'm gonna I'm gonna run out
of here actually I look for a camp at
mom actually a camp will always have a
lit fire to so I won't even need to make
one and how long would you say because
you're saying you can save it and you
will come back to the campaign in a
ballpark so there is an end game like
there is a winning solution to the
campaign how long does it take to get
there um I think it takes around four to
five hours once you really know what
you're doing you know I don't think many
people are gonna sit down the first time
yeah yeah look I'm sure people who are
playing in our in early access we'll be
able to because they know the game
really well but that's you know part of
the idea of it is its knowledge base you
know you figure out how to play it over
time I'm trying to farm down river
faster that is a dangerous game you're
playing oh my god
i think i got it
oh man Oh
no it's fine I got it are you oh no oh
no I don't got it all right so what
kinds of things did you do you lose
items ever or you just harm your boat
and possibly yourself if it's a really
hard impact there's a chance that it'll
delete a random item from one of your
inventories fine point here
otherwise I'm getting pretty hungry I
don't know if I'm gonna find point this
is one of the we're still working on a
couple of performance issues high noon
and it you mentioned before because this
game is pretty close to being done but
you're obviously still tweaking a few
things yeah very much stuff especially
on this is the xbox version but this
game is also coming out on pc yes that's
correct all right i am going to well i'm
here Oh make another traffic yeah well
there's a up at the edge of the screen
right now just Pan the camera up a
little bit wolf yeah you definitely I
didn't see him oh there's actually a
couple wolves how can you see them I
only see there's there one sleeping yeah
this one's sleeping behind them let me
see if there's a third cuz i think i'm
gonna go back to the raft real quick and
I'm willing to I think I've got what I
need to make ah yes you're getting items
from
from your boat yeah you don't have room
to hold yeah so I keep a lot of like
crafting items on my boat just as i
doing did you look it full to you ever
throw away items yeah yeah eventually
let's see alright so you gotta aggro him
I'm gonna I'm just gonna toss this out
there first all right I don't have two
going at me so that's now poison me oh
that's pretty mean alright oh no oh
there's three of them oh this isn't good
that's your plan my plan is probably oh
come on come on buddy get him to go into
the trap my plan is to try and get as
much as I can from these guys while
running oh I missed the impact but he is
super dead yes and i'm just gonna jet
I'm just gonna bail out all right and I
don't know if I'm gonna find a fire
you're pretty hungry did I'm just gonna
I'm just heat them going for it you oh
yeah is it fresh fresh uh-huh all right
okay you got sick yeah yeah so that's
not good fortunate like what do I need
to zoom act I saw into the wild it's not
good all right I actually you have a
parasite you i have i have sumac and i
have water mm-hmm but now i need a fire
okay which you still don't have Flint
yeah which I still don't have for you
and you have a parasite I saw your
vision go hazy for a little bit but it
looks like it's gone now so no I still
have it like you can see like right over
my little stamina bar there's like a
little throbbing thing there but it
won't make you visually it won't disrupt
you know those those happen like when
you get an affliction or when you're
about to die I when they're about to
advance and what kind of oh my gosh I
was
I got some some delicious grubs out of
that all right and you're still hungry
yeah so one of the things that if you
have afflictions they actually make your
stats drop so eating raw meat gives you
like Stalin amount of help oh no and
your cotton t-shirts not have it yeah
exactly well you have a lot of stuff oh
wait but there's a camp okay but it's
gonna rain which means oh I can't start
a fire but I can get the Pleiades you
have a lot come on come on no oh crud
you could have a little problem yes I am
no it's good I got I got this it's under
control you're officially wet yeah oh
there's bus I know you can sleep in
those all right all right you're a dog
here yeah okay often has splints always
has a lit fire although well that's
actually that's kind of incorrect
because the firing ulit if it weren't
raining okay oh good
and you have you guys they're pretty
much feature finally like I said like
you said you're still tweaking a few
things a few hiccups here and there you
guys are gonna finish but you guys are
pretty much close to it yeah we're we're
down to like just sort of performance
issues and whatnot this point oh no no
okay oh no more yeah all right just
leave me alone dude having any luck
today he's right there oh crap oh I got
I got the Flint you got I know I don't
crap I've got a phone inventory you've
been lacerated your wet your t-shirt
isn't working you don't have a parasite
all right let me I'm getting out of this
board way Phillip all right he's gonna
they're very territorial he's gonna lose
interest is your animation changes you
have so much crap going yeah all right
dad I'm just gonna I'm gonna eat these
grubs right now so I'm feeling pretty
good cuz i just ate a bunch of grubs ok
ah alright that cleared out a little
state oh you look inside and defeat it
let me see so I'm gonna see all right so
the intestinal parasites you just work
through over time but they kind of they
make you hungry or faster the laceration
I'm going to need to deal with because
if I don't I'm going to get an infection
and if I don't fear that I guess sepsis
and sepsis will kill me no come on I'm
here the boar yep oh I know I can do so
no dude this dangerous gimme situations
oh we miss you yeah well no all right
forget it I'm not gonna have time to do
with anything I mean maybe I can I might
be able to know this crap you're
building the items or you can actually
don't trap itself yeah alright alright
alright boyfriend I'm going to take a
little vacation from trying to survive
this too just to kill you because I want
his alleble born meets you are hungry I
am very hungry sick and tired and almost
all right come on come on dude all right
yeah oh there you go oh man alright so
now you're gonna build a fire you know
what actually because though yeah no one
she looks terrible yeah alright alright
gonna make a fire
all right wet thickly all you get to sit
next to it yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna warm
right up I'm getting here my wetness
gonna heat and cook me great um
anything's gone well no I need to soon x
oh alright 02 to make the tea oh so
you're not sick anymore yes I'm gonna
I'm gonna live with the bacteria for a
little while longer um can it ever go
away on its own or you talk to Saul that
no so if you look at like when you look
at your afflictions you can see there's
these little progress bars and if
there's nothing at the other end it's
just gonna go away on its own got it
just like real diseases yeah exactly
well yeah kind of you guys don't go away
some time to just go the way yeah risk
it all right hmm do you look at them
close yep I don't have any stitching
kits right now um but let's see no I'm
just tired well I mean things are coming
up milhouse you got a lot of some good
stuff going for you well this is a
really great intro into this game when
ish do you think people can expect to
see it unshelled will have an
announcement very very soon but i'm
shooting for sometime next month ok very
good man yeah absolutely so a nice
Valentine's released that stuff like
that yes we well for thanks so much for
showing showing us the game that was the
flame and the flood you guys can expect
to see that on pc and xbox one pretty
soon yep absolutely not great thank you
so much